going to turn now to a historic move at
the famed New York City Ballet chunwei
Chan first principal dancer of Chinese
descent at the ballet and it's more than
70 year history and he was promoted to
that position in May made his debut as
principal last month in a show that runs
through this weekend as a reminder of
how far we are into the year after that
he's going to prepare for The Nutcracker
because holiday time is coming up fast
Christina raffini met with Chun to learn
about his path to the heights of the
ballet World Christina good morning good
morning guys well George Balanchine one
of the founders of the New York City
Ballet once said I don't want people who
want to dance I want people who have to
dance and nobody embodies that more than
the company's newest leading man
ballet begins in preparation
a routine that starts long before
dancers ever take the stage have you
always wanted to be a dancer I start
dancing with when I was six years old my
sister was in the dance team and I
thought that's so cool and I want to be
a dancer too this season chenway Chan
made his Premiere as principal at the
New York City Ballet he's the first
Chinese dancer to ever hold that
position in the legendary company's
74-year history was this like a lifelong
goal I never
thought about it because it's too big to
think about
chun's journey to Lincoln Center started
20 years ago and more than 8 000 miles
away in Guangdong China we are coming
from very traditional family they want
me to become lawyer a doctor Chan was
accepted to a prestigious National Dance
Academy before reaching his teens but
his parents weren't sold on the idea I
wrote them a letter saying that this is
really what I want to do this is my
decision so even though it's not going
well I would not blame on my parents so
at 12 years old you wrote them a letter
justifying why you wanted to go to this
dance school yeah and did they let you
go they let me go talent and a lot of
hard work landed him on stage in an
international dance competition in
Switzerland
which he lost
but won a life-changing consolation
prize an offer to come to the U.S and
join the Houston Ballet at the age of
18. in China I had been focusing on how
to improve my technique mostly once I
came to America I learned
all those techniques are served to tell
a story and that's changed my mind of
ballet it's not boring at all it's so
much fun
in Texas he learned English and the joys
of social media he also discovered he
could jump really really high feeling
there's a no gravity is one of the best
feeling
I've seen you you look like you're like
on strings it took me a long time
because
how we train in China we cannot jump as
high as we can or we could right away
because they want us to have a good
format good base before we do something
hard now the limits are off and you can
read it then came the biggest jump of
all to New York City what do you like
about Central Park why do you come here
is so true and I love people watching
and people like watching him from his
frequent spontaneous performances around
the city that was the best pirouette and
grass I've ever seen in my life
I did it
[Music]
to a high profile stint on Chinese
reality TV
caught your eye about John Wayne Chen
his absolute professionalism and command
of not only the technique but this
energy that he brought Jonathan Stafford
is the artistic director of the New York
City Ballet home to Legends like
Balanchine and Baryshnikov
he says the company's distinct style
puts less emphasis on the Precision and
uniformity Chun learned in his youth we
want straight lines but we also want the
dancers to dance through the
choreography and if someone pops out a
little bit it's fine they're allowed to
be more open to the audience
learning to balance Chinese and American
dance styles as well as cultures Chun
says has made him a bit of an ambassador
for both do you consider yourself
American you've been here for more than
10 years now yeah I think I would say
this is my second home and I enjoy the
life here so much and
he says he's finally comfortable enough
with English to start teaching adult
classes
a certain former dancer turned TV
correspondent live out a lifelong dream
that was really good
yeah that's amazing why does diversity
help with the company
when you have diversity you're better
when you can have the best of everything
that anyone has to offer you're going to
be better
because even at the top there's their
deal room for improvement for Chen Wei
Chen and the New York City Ballet one of
the reasons I love ballet because
there's no limit and you can always make
it perfect
and it's so challenging that always you
have something to improve on
and if you're wondering if chun's
parents ever came around they were the
first people he called when he was
promoted to principal he said he had
tears in his eyes and he was calling
them and they said this was great but
you know you have to keep working hard
this isn't the end this is only the
beginning I love it I love that reversal
I was like what a way to do it and then
like all right if you're gonna do it you
got to be the absolutely the top of the
top of the top you know this is like if
you think about how many kids dance when
they're little right how many yes how
many people have their kids in dance
class how many of those make a career
out of it and this is the top this is
like not getting in the NFL this is like
being an NFL quarterback you know in a
playoffs I could not take my eyes off of
his legs his legs are amazing incredible
eyes incredible and the calves but let
me say you had some moves
no you did Christine I'm serious I did I
was uh as a as a kid as a kid as a
teenager I was quite serious for a while
missed out on a lot of fun and Chaos in
my youth I knew it tell I saw those
moves but Chris would you like to
pirouette off this off the set over to
there just go show us some moves um I
would not but I do appreciate the offer
don't let Gail set you up for injury in
here but I did like those move Christina
raffini ballerini all right thank you so
much